you can chalk up yet another victory for
progressive democrats here's why the
bite administration
extending its ban on evictions for many
renters
and they'll do it through an order with
the cdc this is happening after the
white house said its hands were tied by
a recent supreme court ruling that came
at the end of june
they lost that ruling here we are in
august and they're going back to it
regardless
republican senator john kennedy
louisiana member of the judiciary
committee sir good day to you
got a few questions for you your
colleague tom cotton tweeted
biden even admits it's unconstitutional
and he concludes with the word
lawless what's going on in that town
well i think it is unconstitutional
that's never stopped
the permanent washington types from
doing something but i do think it's
unconstitutional
and i think it's unwise i don't want
anybody to
to have to to lose their home but look
it's time that we rejoin
the world and we have spent
we meaning the congress about 4.7
trillion dollars helping the american
people recover from the coronavirus our
economy is clearly recovering
in my state we sent louisiana 550
million dollars to help people
with rental assistance we've only spent
50.
so that tells me there's not a big need
there
okay um among your colleagues then
what what do they tell you about the
nash natural forces of capitalism
you know you you can look to some of
these states right now in nebraska
unemployment's two and a half percent
that's awesome and utah it's 2.7 percent
in new hampshire and south dakota it's
2.9 percent
and idaho it's 3 percent so your point
about the economy recovering
is very well taken but at what point do
we
take our foot off the gas well we're
there
we've had a v-shaped recovery uh
we have uh we're now uh generating a
a gdp that uh is
is uh slightly greater than it was
before
the pandemic started we have what 10
million jobs
uh openings that we can't fill uh we set
a record
last quarter we'll probably set a record
this quarter
our economy is is is uh is back
and it's time that now we st we still
have the virus with us which we can talk
about
but it's time to uh to rejoin our lives
and we can't give free rent to everybody
if you want free rent there's nothing
free
bill everything free somebody had to
work for well
that's this is like free rent to
infinity uh i pulled those unemployment
numbers for the wall street journal for
you seize the headline
eviction ban has to end sometime kind of
the point you're making there
tenants and landlords have to work it
out and better now than later but back
to the point
the supreme court said he can't do this
after july well it's august now
should the supreme court have an
emergency ruling and come back and say
that's against the law yes and i suspect
somebody will file suit
and try to get in front of the supreme
court now whether the supreme court will
take the case or not i don't know
but but let me say it again with with
permanent washington types who run this
place
and under this administration make most
of the decisions
the constitution is just a nuisance
you mentioned covet here is your state
where it ranks you're in the bottom five
of vaccinations louisiana checks in
at 37.1 percent behind you alabama
mississippi arkansas and wyoming what's
happening back there that you think the
country needs to understand as to why
people are hesitant well this is america
we're all entitled to our opinion here's
mine
number one the vaccine works
the mrna message tech messenger
technology works
it's the single greatest achievement of
the trump administration
i have i believe in it i've taken two
shots
and if i if they came to me and said in
order to get a booster
you got to take a shot in the eyeball
i'd do it
why because i don't want to die and this
stuff is like playing russian athletic
can kill you
number two if you want to wear a mask in
my opinion you should if you don't you
shouldn't
uh it's the mask issue is not nearly as
important
as trying to get people to seriously
think about taking the vaccine
number three uh we're in a fourth wave
the single biggest thing that has
undermined
our efforts to make of the american
people understand we're in the fourth
wave
is president obama's decision to hold a
birthday bash with 400 people
now i've never seen something so
irresponsible he knows better
he needs to cancel it and have a a beer
and a personal pan pizza at home with
his wife well i've got some breaking
news for you he's done just that
only family and friends he scaled it
back considerably for this weekend well
he needs to cancel it scaling it back
won't get it
noted senator thank you for your time
we'll speak again